[Music]
all right today's question comes from
james in texas james writes my wife and
i
pay our bills based on our income good
james
i earn more so we split the rent 70 30
go
50 50 on the electric bill and i pay for
cable water and internet
when we moved into a new rental she
asked if she could hold off
god i'm just going to finish this
question she asked if she could hold off
paying rent the first two months and i
agreed what a saint the third month she
was late
with her contribution and now she's
going to be late again this month
i ask her to manage her paycheck and
other debts so
that she uses the second check of the
month to save for rent and electricity
to avoid being late and she got mad
it was like she's a little late to the
mad party i'm already there
was i wrong anywhere yeah everywhere
yeah you were
wrong before the whole thing started 100
james everybody both are going to smack
you around are you ready
i was helping her manage her pay what a
what a saint more responsibly because
paying things
late is a bad habit to break you know
what else is a bad habit
being an idiot oh james what are you
doing
it's like he's living with a with a
co-worker
right like they're co-running a business
i don't know man listen dude this is
your wife
you remember the part richer for poorer
in sickness and in health so when you're
laying in the bed with the flu
i hope she doesn't give you as much crap
about making you some chicken soup
because you're sick as you are about
making her be a grown-up and manage her
money by herself oh my god dude
really come on man so um yeah you here's
here's the thing son you guys need to
put your money together together you
work on it together you make decisions
and together we manage
our money for the good of our family
this is not your roommate
the old marriage vows say unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge if you
wanted a roommate you shouldn't have
gotten
married and if you want to divide up
your life
into mine and yours and you owe me this
and that and i'll let you borrow this
from it
man just listen to that language that's
not a marriage
it's not a marriage that's a business
arrangement it's not even a good
friendship no it's not even buddies you
know what we all had this friend in
college that was like hey bro remember
wendy's you owe me 428 from like three
months ago
the mustard that you used in the
refrigerator door that was mine
so you guys are like four dollars dude i
guess
everyone had that friend you know what i
learned about friendship in college i
got around some guys you know what the
fights were about who was covering the
check
like this is ours right that's just
knucklehead college buddies this isn't
a husband and a wife so james you all
have a pronoun issue and
that is y'all got to sit in a room and
say what is yours and mine is ours
that's it right but yours and mine is
ours and we got to do this thing from
the
you're not sanctioning irresponsibility
and she's not going to sanction you
being a control freak
out of control arrogant jerk yes
nobody wants i had enough adjectives
[Laughter]
and i kind of want to hug you man
because you know what i read this and
after you call him an idiot i know hey
that's that's a term of endearment for
me i know i i i want to hug him because
i think he's actually
trying to help and he's asking did i
screw this up
yeah yes you did you did but the the
that
question it's just it is astounding that
you could be that clueless though really
i know but i wonder if that's even a
real question it's endearing
what's endearing is that dumb yeah he's
like hey did i did i mess this up and
everyone's like yeah
of course it's relationally you get a
sub zero score here
no i'm going to give him one one no
because he looked in the mirror and said
maybe it's well now she's pissed why did
this woman wait this long to get pissed
i got to tell you
before the first sentence was over i
don't know billy woman at the ramsey
house would have been over it i'm just
saying
i know but she's getting a free ride
here with it with with this guy that
this this uh romeo who's paying for the
internet
and she won the lottery i'm gonna give
you a little time off on that rent there
just listen
i really like you listen lady i'll get
the internet in the cable
cause that's what men in texas do